What would stop Rodexchitit a large areas of the body?
Further, could this be caused by a dysfunction of my kidneys or liver from my previous diagnosis?
Hodgkin's lymphoma.
For several weeks I have had almost constant itchy treated with copyatitis,
lannolin, arnecitis, and rife itchy programs with little success.
The skin is also very dry.
The almost constant itchy is a rather painful and causing stress.
So there's lots of reasons for skinned or itchy skinned rashes,
depending on if you have a rashed on or raised,
and lots of different questions that should be asked.
But the key component here is this component right here, the lymphoma.
So for some reason that isn't fully understood,
that one of the symptoms of lymphoma, all sorts of types of lymphoma,
is itchy, skin itchy.
Matter of fact, that can be the first sign of lymphoma,
and say a person doesn't have a diagnosis, doesn't know that they have any issue.
And then they have this severe itchy,
and that's what ends up regaining the doctor.
They do a blood test, and if they find out they have lymphoma,
the elevated blood cell tone, etc.
So having a previous diagnosis of lymphoma,
that's the first thing that you need to look at,
is there an optic of lymphoma,
and you want to get some blood work done.
That's the first thing you should think of,
is that is so common with lymphoma.
Now there are some people with lymphoma that never get this symptom,
and there are some that do.
Other pieces of skin itchy, and itchy,
and all of your body can be blockage of the bile duct.
So if the bilirubin of the blood test is elevated,
often a person will see severe itchy throughout their body.
So that's another issue.
There's all sorts of reasons a person could have a allergic reaction
to something that have achieved all over their body issues
with inflammation in the gut.
Could cause itchy in the skin.
There is a gut skin connection,
neurologically, and metabolically.
So I guess the first step for me,
with somebody with a previous diagnosis of lymphoma,
would be to get a full blood workup
and examination to make sure that lymphoma isn't raising its ugly head.
That would be the first thing.
If that has been done,
and you feel like, oh no,
I talked to my oncologist,
I did get blood work,
and there's anything to do with that,
then you have to investigate other things
and we should set up a full consultation
because we may want to investigate the gut issues,
we've had to take these, etc.